well rapper and entertainer Kanye West
appeared on David Letterman's Netflix
show recently while there he said
something pretty true obviously true but
really said out loud the American left
has suddenly decided to believe the rest
of us constantly watch
have you ever been beat up in your high
school for wearing the wrong hat I just
been beat up because people didn't like
me yeah I know what you're saying idea
is the bullying who's the bully in this
scenario definitely liberals will need
people who are Trump supporters it's not
just calm you can't just go and wear the
Hat you can't just go it's like you do
like it's like bro author and columnist
mark Stein often wears the Hat and can
speak directly to this he joined since
today hey mark good to see you what do
you make of this well I love I love
these little Tai Chi as you said Cartier
goes away of air he comes back he's not
look I don't really like the idea of
expanding the the encyclopedia of
Republican celebrities as far as I know
so right now it's got Pat Boone and one
of the Oakridge boys in it and that's
fine by me
but Konya is making an important point
here that it's about the groupthink and
he doesn't see that's that's what he's
on about he doesn't see why he should
get told the parameters within which he
can think and that's actually what's so
sad and pathetic about the the current
crop of celebrities they think they're
edgy they think they're transgressive
they're the least edgy and least
transgressive generation of celebrities
that's ever existed because they're
terrified to move a sixteenth of an inch
outside those parameters and that's all
he's saying he's saying look and one of
the richest most successful celebrities
on the planet why the hell can't I think
a little contrary 'only firm
occasionally they are they are the most
obedient little lemmings never yes
they're the absent orders so but what
would what would truly transgressive
look like in 2019 well I think I think
truly transgressive actually would be
thinking outside the box the Hollywood
box on something like immigration or
diversity or any of the cliches of the
age and it's very actually it's very sad
when you look at counterculture figures
a counterculture has to have a culture
to be counter to and the counterculture
did such a good job that it's now the
establishment and it can't bear to see
itself like that which is why you have
Robert DeNiro and his excesses because
he's actually gotten 81 he's got nothing
to push against anymore and and Kanye
West I think he's just saying couldn't
we at least recognize that celebrity
life is more fun boring Hollywood dinner
parties would be more fun if we at least
allowed two sides to every issue instead
of just as you were doing with Richard
droning on about climate change and
saving the planet can you imagine how
boring that would be and a Hollywood
Beverly Hills what it wouldn't it be
great if Kanye or one of his pals could
say well you know I don't think I don't
think it's such a big deal but there's
not allowed to say that and that's
amazing really man when you say that
I've done that I did that recently if
you won't like that yes they don't
there's only one side and that makes
boring art boring pop-culture and
whether or not Kanye's bonkers I love
him just for busting out of that
occasionally exactly maybe needs to be
insane to do that March time great to
see you tonight thank you
hey thanks a lot Tucker